Mary Jane Willard is a breast cancer survivor.
She has a new lease on life and a new way of expressing herself.
It relaxes you, it relaxes me.
I've learned a lot of different things with the art,...
...with Chinese ink art,...
...and I've made a lot of friends.
She's learning Chinese ink art through M.D. Anderson's COLLAGE program,...
...also known as the Art for Cancer Network.
The class is taught by Peihong Dong Endris,...
...an artist who learned the technique growing up in China.
Endris says the class helps patients forget about their daily struggle with disease...
...and find comfort in their creativity.
I think from this class, even for some people with a difficult time,...
...they can get a short time of peace.
The students say they love this art form and their teacher.
She's very good.
She helps you step by step when she comes, and with each person she demonstrates it with you too.
She gives you that opportunity.
Studies have shown that improvements in mood and outlook can help a patient fight disease.
And although no scientific studies have been carried out on this program,...
...Dr. Wheler says she thinks it helps.
It can't hurt, it can only help,...
...and scientists are trying to be a little bit more rigorous about quantifying the effect.